den
hallo leute hier ist wieder eure mal
wanne und heute ist der 17 april einen
sonntag und ich wollte euch schon immer
meine wohnung zeigen und das ist chabis
gibt es frühstück nummer eins kaffee ist
ruhig das ist schon berlin mag mich
nicht für die skater nicht mitbekommen
haben kann er gestern beim völkerball
für prosieben mit gemacht und sie haben
den zweiten platz gekriegt sehr gut
kelly
eigentlich wollte ich ja heute mit max
zusammen frühstücken aber das mit der
onyx ich legte mich immer viel zu lange
ab 3
den
o
ja ich habe euch erwischt so sitzt
nämlich aus das macht mir mit meiner
ecke hier seht jetzt wahrscheinlich gar
keinen unterschied aber ich fühle mich
einfach besser wenn ich ein bisschen
make-up drauf habe ich habe das gefühl
meine wimpern werden immer länger
die hören nicht auf länger zu werden ich
habe diese krankheit und diese tropfen
und deswegen wachsen hier und morgen von
kingstons das herzstück die couch die
wurde uns zu groß gewählt weil wir
hatten sie eigentlich kleiner bestellt
seinen couch eigentlich zu groß für
unser zimmer und wisst ihr was ich ist
das nimmt und es tut aber kein echtes
kunstwerk aber natürlich warum die so
eine große weiße band ist da und er
strahlt als hierhin zieht am tag x
scheiße war da so eine riesen weiß man
das aber wenn man abends danach guckt
das ist ein brief in der sonne
das allerwichtigste hier in der wohnung
lag jetzt bei 1 mittels das
allerwichtigste ist das allerwichtigste
der katzen zu mir richtig lustig ist
weil die nachstellung schatten stellen
auch einstellen sein reha einrichtung
jetzt war
hier seht ihr meine heimliche
leidenschaft eine ps3 eine ps4 eine xbox
one und eine xbox 360 heimlich weil der
fall ist
nein nein nein nein nein nein
ab
dpa
katzen sind so süß aber manchmal nerven
sie auch nur deswegen gehen wir jetzt
weiter ins arbeitszimmer
wer dieses chaos das ist mein
arbeitszimmer und mein schreibtisch das
müssen wir jetzt aufbauen
okay das muss erst mal reichen die macht
casey nässe das ist voll schwer die
kamera dann passiert die ganze magie
also richtig für die vor mit diesem raum
also die andere hälfte gehört max sieht
man natürlich überhaupt nicht dass das
hier männerbereich ist was hast du denn
da ja das sollte eigentlich noch diese
anzug da drauf aber er macht nicht weil
ich es fauler mensch und sagt wie man
nehme ich brauche aber flo werden nicht
helfen
gitarren und natürlich ein bisschen
vanessa hier drin
zucker sterne und winke kannte die nicht
mal links mal bevor erweiterung für ihre
muss ich mich an die babys kümmern weil
ich hab hier so kein langelage da ist
nagellack hier gar keine nagellack
wieder und ich hasse es wenn meine
fingernägel abgebrochen sind und so da
muss ich mich jetzt einmal noch mal drum
kümmern
erst muss der alten nagellack ab finger
rein es ist so einfach
falls sie mal das man nicht kennt
genauso funktioniert ist es ist ein
schwamm mit einem loch den finger da
sein ich weiß nicht woran man denkt
hat
dpa
unsere dusche hallo ich meine absolute
lieblingsstadt schlafbereich einen
schlafbereich
warum kann ich das nicht machen hinten
ruhig muss sich jetzt zeigen
ich muss auch sagen ich muss etwas
zeigen die neon kendall
wer ist denn bitte in dem neo neon
gesicht ich liebe dieses plakats simone
gemacht hier grüßen simone das ist super
schön gemacht natürlich wegen einem
hübschen gesicht aber schränkt sagen
warum der kleiderschrank ordentlich
aussieht das kommt halt auch nicht warum
meine ordentlicher sieht er max es aber
ich auch zu einer farben sortiert und
wir sagen tschüss
jetzt machen wir das was wir jeden
sonntag machen